How should a real man speak to other
people? The way you speak to other
people influences not only how they
react to you but also what they think
about you. It tells people a lot about
you. Who you are as a person.
Luckily we can always improve the way we speak to other people, so in this video
I'm gonna talk about 12 tips and how a
real man should speak to other people
let's not waste any more time let's get
right into the video:
Hey guys welcome to my channel. If this is the first time that you're here, I'm Daniel
Consider subscribing and also thinking
that notification well so you won't miss
any of the next videos. Now let's start
with the first tip.
A real man never ever talks down on anybody.
It doesn't matter who they are. Nothing makes me more angrier
than this. You see those guys that just talks down on people to try and lift
themselves up. It's disgusting.
Some people think that because they
achieved some kind of success by reading a great book or becoming a celebrity or obtaining a
very high position in some kind of firm.
Then they think they have the authority to talk
down on people. It's disgusting. It doesn't
matter what you've achieved in life, what
kind of race you are, who you are, what
job you have... It doesn't matter. You never
ever speak down to anybody else. Pride
makes us artificial but humility makes
us real.
Don't be afraid to be heard. There's a
lot of guys out there that feel like
they don't have that deep voice. Well
actually that deep voice doesn't really
matter that much. We all have different
voices and we use different tones when
we speak to people, but the problem is
that fear. That's fear for when I speak
people are not gonna like my voice and
so it bothers you. It also
changes the way you speak to people and
it's a psychological thing. Now even if
you don't have a deep voice. If you're
not afraid to speak. To be heard. You're
gonna speak in a way where people is
gonna look at you and view you as
somebody with a strong voice with a strong opinion. It's all psychological
Pleas. It is one simple word. I don't know why most parents don't teach their kids these
basic rules of just saying please. It
doesn't matter what they do even if they
just get you a cup of coffee and they
say hey do you want a cup of coffee. You
say yes please. It's one word that just
shows this person that you have respect
for them that you appreciate what they
want to do for you and it shows that you
have manners
Don't talk so loud. You know that type of
guy who steps into the room and he needs
attention. He wants attention so he
raises his voice and he speaks very loud
even if the guy's just here next to him
and he can just talk normally he would
be like: "hey how are you doing ah man..."  and everybody in the room looks at
him.
This guy realizes everybody is looking at
him. He thinks: "wow I'm so cool
everybody's looking at me I have
attention" and the people that looks at
him they're thinking: "who is this guy
that just has no manners and just talk
so loud". See what I'm saying.
When you're speaking to somebody you're
standing next to them, so you don't have to
speak too soft so they cannot hear you
or too loud. Just speak normally. Be
normal. They're not miles away you don't
have to yell
say thank you. Two words very
simple very easy thank you.
It blows my mind why people cannot say
that anymore today. I mean even if you
drop something and somebody picks it up
you give it to them say thank you.
There's so many times where I do certain
things and I help people with certain things
like picking up stuff giving it to them
they just take it and look at me and walk
on... They have no appreciation and I'm
just like, can you believe this... Or even
driving and you give somebody like yeah
you can you can. Go first, you know, and
then people just like... they just go and
instead of just saying thank you and
then go. It doesn't matter what it is.
Say thank you to show the person that you appreciate what they're doing for you
You stand by what you say and what you
believe in with your body language. Don't
slouch. Don't look away while you talk
and you're speaking to this person and
you're like like this...mumble... No stand up straight. Look them in the eye and say your say.
Not in an arrogant way be humble be
kind but say your say and then show people
that you're confident in what you're
saying and what you believe in.
You know I feel like we are
entering an age where
people are having less and less
manners. Like for example interrupting
people. A real man never interrupts
someone unless this person is being very
rude, right? But if you interrupt somebody
it shows them that you're not really
interested in what they're saying and
you cannot even wait just a few seconds
to speak. Unless you're speaking with some
woman that really loves talking a lot (joking)...
You know I heard this joke about the
husband and wife and the husband said: "you know I stopped talking to my wife for
five years" and they asked  "why? "Well", he said: "well because I didn't want to
interrupt her"...
Say I'm sorry. It's so hard for a lot of
people to say I'm sorry because they
have so much pride but you know
sometimes we just gotta shut up, accept
we were wrong, swallow our pride and say
I'm sorry. It's not giving up it's
growing up. Nobody is perfect, right? We all make mistakes, but a real man
takes responsibility for his mistakes.
He man's up, he owns his mistakes and he
says I'm sorry.
Profanity or cursing on a
regular basis. Do you swear so much
sometimes that you don't even realize
how much you're swearing? If you can't be
interesting without swearing then you
have to know that there's a problem. You
don't need to use profanity or cursing,
swearing all the time to try and sound
funny or interesting or make people like
you. If you swear or curse a lot you lose
credibility with a lot of people. I see
it in the comments all the time and I delete
people who swear. There's been a lot of
studies on this and scientist says that
if you use profanity on a regular basis
then people see you more as being
dishonest and less intelligent than your
peers.
Don't gossip. It's disgusting. If it's not your story to tell
don't tell it.
Rumors are carried by haters, spread
by fools and accepted by idiots and
remember those who gossip with you will
gossip about you.
You know I think so many problems in the
world would disappear if we decide to
talk to each other instead of about each
other.
A real man. A gentleman never says
hateful things about someone's sex, race,
color, culture or anything else. They don't
judge a book by its cover. They get to
know the person first. If you judge
another person based on these things then
you don't define them you define
yourself.
A real man speaks in a positive
manner. He builds people up, he makes them
feel good. He lifts the spirits of
everybody around him. You've met those
guys who are just negative about
everything in life. It doesn't matter
what they experience, even if it's a nice
day outside or they have experienced
something nice then they always have
something negative to say. A real man
does not do that. Change your way of
thinking by focusing on the good things
in your life, because your thoughts
becomes your words and the words that
you say becomes the house that you live
in.
if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video
cheers guys